in my opinion the crisis was primarily
created by government policies
specifically the Federal Reserve printed
too much money on the Greenspan where we
had negative real interest rates for two
years and then Bernanke inverted you
interest rates and which created
terrible pressure on brain bank margins
we couldn't have had a bubble in the
economy if the Fed hadn't printed too
much money it ended up in the housing
market because of freddie mac and fannie
mae these two giant government-sponsored
enterprises so it wasn't really the
regulatory structure that that created
the problems it was government policy
from the Fed and through freddie mac and
fannie mae and what is irony is the
perception that the banking industry was
deregulated in fact the regulatory
environment during the bubble i was the
worst in my career it was just miss
regulation there's a huge amount of
focus on soybeans oxy a huge amount of
focus on the Patriot Act and no focus
really on traditional risk management so
they may they contributed to the crisis
more in an indirect way but the real
cause of the miss allocations in the
economic system came from the Federal
Reserve and Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae
I was very opposed to the tarp program
in fact I wrote Congress and tried very
hard to keep cart from happening
unfortunately however once tarp and was
approved by Congress there was a
significant regulatory pressure placed
on all the large financial institution
to participate in tarp particularly all
100 billion dollar and over banks the
pressure was based on Bernanke study the
Great Depression where Roosevelt tried
to bail out individual companies and the
market reacted when he did that at the
time that talk was instituted there were
three large financial institutions that
were under stress but Bernanke didn't
want to bail those three out because
it'd be obvious he was helping helping
them so he use regulatory I mean intense
regulatory pressure to encourage all the
100 billion dollar and over institutions
to participate tarp was really a
negative for the healthy financial
institutions we didn't need the capital
and we had to pay very high interest
rate they got warrants and so it was
really a subsidy for the unhealthy
institutions at the expense of the
healthy institutions BB&T was one of the
first banks to pay back tarp we paid it
back as quickly as we possibly could
all the large financial institutions 100
billion dollar plus institutions were
basically strongly encouraged
effectively forced to participate in
tarp because the Federal Reserve didn't
want the market to know that the
specific institutions that were being
bailed out and by encouraging everybody
including the strong institutions to
participate they obscured the fact that
certain institutions for being saved if
you didn't need the capital the fact
that you had to pay a very high interest
rate and give warrants to the government
was very expensive in our case that was
several hundred million dollars probably
and it turned out when they did the
stress test we didn't we really didn't
need the capital anyway so I thought it
was a redistribution from the healthy
institutions to the unhealthy
institutions and not good government
policy although they had created such a
panic they may have needed to do
something but I don't think tarp was the
answer
I think the long-term consequences are
very negative and the classic example is
gmac gmac is the automobile finance arm
of General Motors gmac contributed a lot
to the problem we have in the automobile
business in order to sell Alma Beals a
number of years ago they invented the
one hundred percent car loan payable
over seven years and what that meant is
most people owe more on their car than
it was worth after three or four years
so they can't go buy a new car and now
and of course you may see got a lot of
cars back and had huge losses in that
regard and now the government keeps
pouring money into gmac keeping them in
business under the theory that there's
no financing for automobiles which is
not true people like us are in the car
business we just don't want aren't going
to do the dumb stuff that gmac is doing
and you can't miss allocate capital
invest in things that shouldn't be done
and raise your standard of living in the
long term and and that's what government
policy is doing so poorly what
institutions need to fail and then at
council gets reallocated to better run
institutions that's the way Marcus work
you have to have a downside and I do
think that the healthy institutions have
definitely been hurt hurt badly by
keeping the unhealthy institutions in
business because these unhealthy
competitors are continuing to do things
that drive down margins of profitability
for the healthy institutions you could
see healthy institutions in trouble
because of keeping the unhealthy in
business
well it should be noted that the reason
we had the low down payments was cause
of government policy it was a very
strong government policy to increase the
homeownership rape above the natural
market rate that was specifically
executed through Freddie Mac and Fannie
Mae and who were very dominant in the
affordable housing now subprime market
it's being executed today by the FHA so
what we really need to do is get the
government out of the home lending
business let home lending bill ending go
back to traditional banks like it was in
the savings and loan industry years ago
before the industry was destroyed by a
hyper inflation and high interest rates
and and that would impose a discipline I
don't think the government should sit
said set minimum down payments on
the other hand they shouldn't encourage
no down payments and low down payments
which is really what they have been
doing
well BB&T certainly we've had our
challenges and and we always have made
mistakes but we have done much better
than other financial institutions and I
primarily think it's because of the
value system we have at BB&T we've had
some good strategies and good execution
but they're very secondary to the fact
that we were very much a principle
driven organization we've had a very
strong culture around ethics and values
for a long period of time and we've
reinforced that over and over again and
that value system is based on
rationality which demands honesty
demands integrity I demands a long-term
perspective on your business and it's
caused us to do some things like
refusing to make loans where eminent
domain was used to take property from
one individual to another individual
interestingly enough our value system
kept us from making the the negative
amortization or what are the pic of
payment mortgages remember pick a
payment mortgages where somebody buys a
house and their interest is a thousand
dollars a month but they only pay five
hundred dollars a month we chose not to
do those kind of mortgages not over some
grand inside because of the time you
could economic in cycles at the time you
could sell them in the secondary market
but because one of the fundamental
commitments in our mission to help our
clients achieve economic success and
financial security we expect to make a
profit doing it but we don't consciously
want to ever do anything that's bad for
our clients we knew real estate markets
wouldn't appreciate at ten percent a
year for every week we didn't expect him
to depreciate like they had but we knew
that people would be taken in order and
risk with those pic of payment mortgages
and we chose not to do them over ethics
not over economics so BB&T strength I
believe it's been its value system
I think lacks regulation played very
little rule I think it was an it was
incentive the government was trying to
raise the homeownership rate above the
national market rate was a very it was a
stage of objective of the Clinton
administration a stated objective of the
bush administrating they were pushing
affordable housing xiety subprime
lending it was a government policy so it
was it wasn't just thought it was it
wasn't the lacs regulation it was a goal
to make more risky home mortgages they
thought it was a good thing so it's I
like that a lot of the same people now
that are criticizing the industry like
barney frank and Chris died with the
people that were most supportive of
affordable housing programs yes market
participants made mistakes but in the
context of a government stated goal of
raising homeownership above the natural
market rate I go supported subprime
lending
I definitely think it would have been
feasible and I definitely think it
didn't better off in the long term it's
difficult to argue about whether we've
been better off in the short term I
think that's a complicated question but
in the long term it'd be much much
better off in my career Citigroup has
failed three times been bailed out by
the government three times and every
time they've gotten bigger and worse
there is a tremendous moral hazard to
the government constantly keeping poor
run institutions in business and and it
prevents a natural market correction
process so we shouldn't been in a
situation if we hadn't had the fed over
expanding the money supply and what
happened with affordable housing through
government policy we wouldn't have been
in the shape we were in but given the
situation the triage a solution would
have really been a better solution
I don't think the about capital ratio is
a big bang should be hired in small
banks in fact my my experience is
exactly opposite the small banks and
ones that tend to be the most
undercapitalized particularly startup
small banks but I think everybody's
capital ratios I'll be higher I think
that government policy is encouraged
banks have lower capital than they
should one of my cures long-term for the
industry is not my optimal cure but it's
a more practical here would be to set a
goal for banks to have twenty
twenty-five percent equity give them a
long-term time to do and shift the risk
from the taxpayers back to the
shareholders of the bank it would also
answer the too-big-to-fail questioning
that either city court could raise that
kind of capital or not and they couldn't
then they would then they'd have to
shrink now it's very important that be
combined with several things when we
need to reduce FDIC insurance back to
the hundred-thousand-dollar level to
take out that risk secondly we need to
make it explicitly clear the Federal
Reserve can't bail out general electric
or non banks because banks have to have
a special proxy if they have to have a
higher capital levels and it should be
against the law for general eckerd to be
bailed out by the Federal Reserve and
finally you have to eliminate about 90
or 95 percent of the regulations that
impact the industry because the industry
can't afford to have higher capital
levels and a huge regulatory burden so
we ought to shift the risks back to
shareholders twenty twenty-five percent
pure kappa for all all banks in a
long-term systemic fashion but that put
coordinated with substantially reduced
regulation so the industry can be
competitive health and healthy
well my general posture is that I am
opposed to any trust on the other hand
if the government is determined some
institutions are too big to fail then
they have to be broken up because it
creates huge market distortions
particularly in the good times because
anybody that has an implicit government
guarantee can afford to take
dramatically more risk so what's going
to happen if we don't break up the
institutions that are too big to fail
then they on the next cycle and the good
times come they'll come they'll be
taking enormous risk and then the next
cycle will be a really a disaster I
personally don't believe they're too big
to fail I think they should be allowed
to fail and there ought to be a process
where they failed just like any other
company and then you wouldn't have to
break them up the capital requirement
that I described a book in the last
answer last question really would help
feel very effectively with this issue
I think executive compensation ought to
be set by the market place boards do
make mistakes sometimes in the executive
compensation process I think there's
been some obvious abuse of executive
compensation in a few cases but I think
the more generic problem is not that
people can be paid well but the
measurement of performance is not right
and I think the two errors that have
been made one a lot of times performance
is measured to linearly it doesn't
include the comprehensive performance
and secondly a lot of times performance
is too short term so i think that board
should be setting compensation i think
highly performing people are be paid
very well based on market conditions but
i think boards should do a good job and
I think frankly I think our board has
done a good job being sure the
compensation is not just linear and
being sure it covers a long period of
time not just what happens over a short
period
I think that the shareholders have to
select the board members and the board
members have to make those kind of
operating decisions I don't think
shareholders have enough information to
make concrete operating decisions they
could put the board in the position they
simply couldn't attract the kind of
talent that they need to operate we're
seeing that right now with some of the
the interference by the government in
saying executive compensation I do think
shareholders should be very careful in
selecting the board members I would say
this though I don't think shareholders
have been unduly particularly
institutional shareholders in what's
been going on recently because a lot of
shareholders are very short-term
oriented and so they encourage
short-term performance and they give
executives that act in the short term
manner so I think if shareholders want a
different long-term results and they
need to invest with a longer-term
perspective and that's a really
important responsibility versus
micromanaging the board process
if I were in charge I would go to a
private banking system and a monetary
standard based on market criteria which
would probably be a gold standard not
cuz there's anything magical about gold
but because goal was limited it's hard
to find it's expensive and it provides
discipline as long as we have a Federal
Reserve we're going to have a high level
of government debt until we get in
serious financial trouble it's almost
inevitable if you look governments have
been basing the currency since at least
the Roman Empire I'm even before that
and we have been to basing our currency
and we will get in trouble if we if we
if we don't go to a goal a gold standard
in a private banking system that I think
the federal reserve all I had less power
not more we ought to go with what Milton
Friedman said and grow the money supply
to fix rate like three percent because
every time they overcorrect you don't
know that the over Corrections happened
until two or three years down the road
and we're looking at that same kind of
risks right now stagflation in the
future and then the other option would
be the one I described before with more
counseling less regulation which is a
very practical option and almost the
opposite of the direction we're going
now with just plain more regulation
we're going to make the system more
vulnerable not less vulnerable
I think that the primary calls the
financial prices was government policy
we don't live in a free market in the
u.s. we live in a mixed economy the the
mixture depends a lot on the industry of
technology is probably eighty percent
free twenty percent government financial
services is seventy percent government
thirty percent free not surprising the
most regulated industries one that had
the biggest problems what happened is
government policy created a bubble in
the residential real estate markets that
bubble burst which bubbles always do and
that got transmitted into the capital
markets and in the economy in general it
is true that individual financial
institutions made some really big
mistakes but it was in context of
government policy errors and the three
big causes were first the Federal
Reserve in a certain sense people don't
they know this but they don't get it the
government owns a monetary system in the
US and 1913 the monetary system was
nationalized if you're having trouble in
the monetary system by definition it's a
problem of government policy if you
interstate highway bridges were falling
down people say well it's wrong with the
government they only known the highways
they own the monetary system the Fed was
created to take out volatility in the
economy with what they've done is take
out short-term volatility and push
problems into the future because in a
free market as human beings we're not
omniscient we're always it's always in a
correction process good businesses are
growing bad business of going out of
business if you take out the bottom side
you push the problems into the future
and then specifically Alan Greenspan had
negative real interest rates for several
years but now he created inverted yield
curve those are huge incentives for
people to invest and take and take high
levels of risk we couldn't have had a
financial crisis of governor Federer's
I've had in print of the money the FDIC
creates alike a market discipline where
people like golden west sand and indie
magd at all and countrywide all that
failed it can grow their assets high
risk assets very easily by buying
deposits and because the FDIC insurance
a typical depositor doesn't think about
the risk in the institution they're
invested in and then it ended up in the
housing market because of a goal really
set 1999 by Bill Clinton prophetic mac
and fannie mae to have over half their
loan portfolio in an affordable housing
and so a lot of the bob
ended up in the housing market and
Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae would never
have existed in a free market they were
guaranteed by the federal government
when they went broke they were leveraged
a thousand to one and they had five
trillion dollars in liabilities and
politics played a huge role I personally
was involved in a committee trying to do
something about Freddie Mac and Fannie
Mae cuz you could run the numbers and
you knew they were going broke but
Congress wouldn't do anything about it
because affordable housing was kind of a
religious belief of Congress and
secondly Freddie many of her huge
contributors to both Democratic parties
so yes individual financial institutions
made mistakes but in the context of some
really serious government policy errors
I totally agree and I think we're
getting rid of deposit insurance would
be wonderful in fact 10-15 years ago the
Financial Services Roundtable actually
went through an exercise looking at a
cross guarantee program among the large
financial institutions I believe if we
put that program in place similar to
what happens with the insurance industry
with the broker industry has we would
never have had even with the Federal
Reserve even with freddie mac and fannie
mae we certainly would have had a miss a
l'occasion of the magnitude we had
Deposit Insurance played a huge role in
the big failures in the golden west and
the country wise and Washington Mutual
etc etc and the reason for that is the
FDIC this is my experience of that
career in good times they don't really
impose any kind of discipline and then
in bad times they overreact right now
the FDIC is tightening like crazy making
it much harder to make loans now they
say they want you to make loans but they
really don't because the local examiner
all he can do it all it can happen in
him is his bank get in trouble so the
FDIC and the federal examiners are
tightening bank standards now after the
horses out of the barn in the good times
they weren't really paying any attention
we've taken over some failed
institutions and it was obvious in these
cases that these people were making bad
loans good examiner's would have shown
that but they don't they don't act too
laughs after the fact if we had a
coinsurance pool where the banks really
were taking the risk we would be far
more disciplined to make sure the cut
the companies that were in our co
insurance people had enough capital and
had the proper kind of risk standards so
I'd vote to get rid of FDIC insurance
not that we don't need it we need some
kind of insurance but I think that it
ought to be an industry based in DC
control pool where we would have a huge
motivation to discipline all the
participants in the pool
I don't think the market per se failed I
think that government policies create
market distortions I too much money with
the Federal Reserve the allocation the
housing there was one factor that
created an odd market failure and that
was fair value accounting fair value
accounting is supposed to be a good
thing because it's marked to market but
in a in a panic situation the market is
not functioning it's not it's not a
market failure it's just the nature of
panics and and that created distortions
and I'll give you a simple way that that
happened let's say there was a mortgage
bond in the market that that it had
originally been 100 million dollars but
because of mortgages not being paid
under the bond and people that weren't
expected to pay in the future
economically that mortgage was worth 80
million dollars and that's what it
should have sold for but because of the
panic the only buyers were deep
discounters that would only pay 50
million dollars for it now that had big
implications because under this fair
value accounting the financial
institution instead of marking the
mortgage down twenty bond down 20
million dollars had to mark it down 50
million dollars financial institutions
banks or leverage will just use an easy
number ten to one so instead of
destroying two hundred million dollars
worth of lending capacity which the loss
of 20 million dollars in capital would
do it destroyed five hundred million
dollars in lending capacity I 50 times
10 instead of 20 times ten because of
the counting system but here's why the
market didn't work was wide in the
market correct that there are people
like BB&T that had plenty of money we
saw that bottles worth 80 million
dollars we could buy it for 50 if we
went in and started buying and everybody
else like us had money started buying
the price would have gotten certainly
close up to the 80 million but we
wouldn't buy because we couldn't take
the accounting risk because even though
we knew the bond was worth 80 million
dollars we weren't going to buy it even
for 50 min because we didn't know that
next quarter under this panicky market
it would only be a fair market value
quote would only be 40 million cuz
everybody would be scared and we'd have
to take a markdown so fair value
accounting created a market distortion
that
never would have existed in a free
market I would just point out that the
SEC makes the accounting rules in the US
we do not have a private based
accounting system I don't know of any
big firm that runs their internal
operations based on GAAP accounting I
don't know of any hedge fund that runs
their operations based on gaffa County
and so the SEC ironically through the
control of the accounting system created
in a market distortion that I do not
believe would have existed in a pure in
a pure free market
I don't believe so I mean I think that
government intervention in the long term
almost always creates poor economic
allocation processes you can make some
arguments in the middle of a painting
the government inefficient helps you in
the short term but the long-term price
for government interference is very high
let's face it the United States faces
some really significant long-term
economic challenges however we feel I
think the economy's in some kind of
recovery I think are most likely
intermediate a scenario is kind of a
stagflation environment but not really
worried about the US 20 and 25 years
down the road we got huge deficits and
Social Security he's deficit in Medicare
we got trillion dollar plus operating
deficits a dysfunctional foreign policy
we got a big problem with the
demographics with the retiring baby
boomers we got a fail K through 12
education system you can paint a very
scary fixture 25 years down the road if
we don't if we don't provide the
discipline that's that's necessary and
what that means is not more government
regulation but a return to what made
America great in the first place
individual rights free markets
entrepreneurship increases in
productivity you can't print your way
out of problems if you could Zimbabwe
we'd be doing great right somebody gave
me a trillion dollars in Bali whatever
it is bill the other day and said it was
worth five cents you have to produce
your way and we need to create the kind
of environment where productive people
are encouraged to be taped rational
risks and grow their businesses and we
haven't been doing that so that's our
real problem not market failure
I think the long-term implications are
very detrimental if you want to really
think about what happened in the housing
crisis it was a government policy
through Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae and
affordable housing policies but they
call it community reinvestment act etc
that created a massive misallocation of
credit if the government gets into
allocating credit over time it will make
sure we aren't as productive as we
should be so the government regulation
is usually in the end look like credit
allocations usually to those that are
politically favored at the expense of
making sure credit is allocated to the
most productive segments in the economy
so I think government regulation in the
long term is almost always destructive